Last question today is from Nico.
Nico wrote in and said, Hey David, what's
the most unrealistic democratic campaign promise
of 2020 so far?
Obviously Donald Trump all along was making
unrealistic campaign promises, but what are
unrealistic ones from the left?
So there's two ways to answer this question.
There's the micro answer and there's the macro
answer.
If you want to play the micro of specific
policy, there are lots of policies that are
unrealistic in the sense that they ignore
that you would need as president, both the
House and Senate to be democratically controlled
in order to make them a reality almost guaranteed.
Okay, so medicare for all for example, how
do you do Medicare for all without control
of the Senate in 2020 yes, it's possible in
the hypothetical sense, it's extraordinarily
unlikely.
There's certain infrastructure stuff that's
not realistic in terms of its political viability
without control of the House and Senate and
you have to understand that we have many examples
even with control by the same party of the
White House, the house in the Senate, it's
still hard to do stuff.
Universal background checks.
When Barack Obama was in the White House and
controlled the House and Senate, 90% support
for that from the American public.
Still couldn't get it done.
Gun lobby significantly to blame there.
But the point is there are lots of policies
that are effectively nonstarters if you don't
control the White House, the Senate and the
House of Representatives.
But that's the micro.
I think this question is more interestingly
addressed at the macro level.
The most unrealistic metta or macro promise
is bipartisanship.
Everybody pays lip service to bipartisanship.
I know how to work with the other side.
I have a long history of drafting and sponsoring
legislation with people from the other side
of the aisle.
I would work together in ways that other candidates
aren't able to.
I don't think it's a bad idea.
It's just completely unrealistic.
The last 30 years have increased polarization
have shown us this.
I did a story on the Monday show talking about
how Donald Trump is in practice.
Just a symptom of the problem, which has been
the rise in reactionary politics from the
right for the last 20 to 30 years.
Depending on how you want to measure it.
Republicans won't even call out Trump for
relatively minor things.
You're not going to get real bipartisanship
in this environment.
There's no upside to even trying to get bipartisanship
the way our political system is designed and
you actually risk your own party turning against
you, uh, if you start working with the other
side.
So I'm not saying I don't want bipartisanship.
I'm not saying that the people promising it
are straight up lying or don't want it themselves.
What I'm telling you is that if you ask me
what's the most unrealistic promise we hear
from Democratic candidates is that they are
going to be able to work with Republicans
if they are elected Republicans who likely
will control the Senate after 2020 and get
stuff done.
They will have to get stuff done despite Republicans.
I would love to hear them just say that, and
that's the most unrealistic promise that we're
hearing.
Um, that's it for today.
We've got a great bonus show.
Keeps sending in questions for next week.
Become a member or a patron to get instant
access to the bonus show, www dot [inaudible]
dot com or [inaudible] dot com slash David
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.